this is a true story of Ian
martinborough who came out of nowhere
dreamed big enough and came through with
it
this is Jan martinborough and he is a
young British arrest card driver my
obsession as a child was to become a
racing driver he had no understanding of
the racing World apart from a video game
I started playing Gran Turismo on the
PlayStation and then when I was 19 I
remember seeing her on a normal TV
advert GT Academy a chance to become a
professional racing driver for Nissan I
didn't have any experience driving
anything and then eight months later I'm
driving this car at 140 miles an hour
he's sitting on a couch playing a video
game and he winds up becoming a great
race car driver
but to have a film made about it I never
thought that was even possible I think
it's maybe the first film ever where
there's a film being made about
someone's life and they are stunt
driving in the film
it's on set it's very surreal
scale and the attention to detail and
the car it blew my mind I have nothing
but respect for Yan being in the card is
the most difficult thing I have ever
done Jan has this Burning passion and
desire to achieve more than what his
circumstances were allowing that is
unbelievably inspiring
let's go
[Music]